do the right thing and then get punished
athletic wear brand Lululemon facing a
lot of criticism after firing two
employees who recorded and called in
this robbery to police
no no
seriously get out
get out
the workers chasing Mass robbers out of
their store before calling the cops and
the thieves were later arrested but
Lululemon claims it has a zero tolerance
policy for pursuing shoplifters
according to the company the Safety and
Security of our employees and guests is
always Lululemon's top priority and we
have policies and protocols in place to
uphold a safe environment one of the now
fired employees says that she didn't
feel supported after the store had
previously been robbed multiple times
the theft also was for seven thousand
dollars these three two teens and a 20
year old they sold seven thousand
dollars worth of workout gear Harold
this is not like a teenager's slipping a
Snickers bar into his pocket and walking
out of a grocery store this is organized
felony theft and the store seem to not
want to do anything about it
so I I I I'd sympathize with this young
worker I have a perspective on this it's
a little different my wife was in a
Lululemon store here in New York City
that was that was uh burglarized it was
robbed she came out of the store it all
happened in like a minute minute and a
half she came out of the store and
called me and she was shaking and and
was told afterwards that the store has a
policy where they don't want this thing
to escalate if they have insurance for
this stuff and they don't want to
endanger their employees or their the uh
the the customers
um this situation here is unique because
this young employee said this is a
repeat offense uh and
um I could what I don't understand what
their policy is if the an employee or or
a customer is in day it feels like their
life is in danger they're threatened by
someone how do you behave but I get
where the the store is coming from they
actually caught the people that robbed
the store my wife was in about an hour
later so they had some way of going
about doing it but they need to probably
revisit the policy but I get I get what
they're thinking about on this and I
think my wife I'm glad that she turned
that everything was okay there but I do
wonder if the employees Greg sit there
and think okay so you're just going to
let all of these all these merchandise
be stolen and why are we here yeah right
like this is the thing I think Lululemon
it forgets it there are people that work
want to work for you that take pride in
what they do and and keeping a
professional atmosphere I know that to
some people when you go into a store you
don't might feel but they're about
people that might like the fact that
everything is neatly stacked that people
try things on that that it's a nice
place to work and then when somebody
comes in it's like you're introduced to
a new boss the people that manage you
aren't really your manager it's this
group of thugs they actually have more
control over the store than you do we
can't we keep thinking that oh you know
that it was going to be Amazon that
killed brick and mortar stores it's not
it's thieves and it's insurance
companies thieves rape the business and
insurance companies say don't resist and
this is what you want you're watching
these businesses in free fall and it's
not because of boycotts you know it's
because they have no solution or policy
regarding these uh what's really a
fundamental breakdown in society this is
what happens when groups of people are
told
that even though it's against the law
we're not going to stop you the law is
no longer enforced it's over it's over
these stores are going to go away
because they don't have the balls to
actually do anything about it I think
everybody should carry a gun that's my
opinion all right we'll continue that I
just thought I'd throw that in there for
the hell of it because I was boring
myself
judge so they were arrested it is felony
robbery they remain in custody at the
moment but do you think they'll do any
time
I have no idea I don't know who the D.A
is I don't know if they take it
seriously their second felony offenders
apparently and so they should serve time
who knows where did this happen I think
Atlanta Georgia Georgia yeah yeah they
got a real problem there you know I I
want to I want to speak to the to the
employees who were upset about this and
were taking the pictures it seems to me
they were taking the pictures this is
not from a camera in the store it
doesn't right it doesn't it turned us
over so but for that employee taking
those pictures and the one kid who came
back in the door and they got a full
face and then when I was D.A we had a
high intensity drug trafficking uh uh
section where we could put faces in it
could be identified almost immediately
if the person had a record so but for
that employee they wouldn't have
arrested those guys but I'm an employee
I have to pay to be able to get to work
pay for parking pay for transportation
then I have to pay for my lunch then I
have to work and if I want to get that
shirt that I love because I work at
Lululemon because I love of what they
sell I get a 30 discount you damn right
I'm infuriated you're damn right I'm
going to tell them instinctively without
even thinking about it hey you don't
have a right to take that and I am going
to chase them they didn't chase them
with a weapon they didn't chase them
outside the store they did a video they
said hey come back you know what we lost
a billion dollars a year in terms of
thefts if they think if they'd rather
lose a billion dollars a year let them
go out of business as opposed to at
least giving an employee an ability to
say stop it like what if they what if
Lululemon or other retail stores were to
give a spot bonus to anybody who was
willing to at least try to stop a
robbery I'd be working at Lulu over the
weekends Dana that'd be great I have
speed I have agility I have cat light
reflexes and I myself have been tempted
to steal from Lululemon I went in there
and got some Christmas stuff for Emma it
was like 350 dollars for a little jogger
I could have cleaned that place out but
this thing is this
this is what happens when you make white
people feel guilty about being white
right
you have all of this money okay and all
of these successful businesses and then
teens come in and Rob you and you say
you're not allowed to do anything about
it you're not allowed to prosecute not
even allowed to film and that's what
happens in this country you have to
treat everybody equally does it matter
who you are what you look like how old
you are if someone comes into the store
he could be a white guy with a beard if
he's tucking Lulu's under his lapels you
have to prosecute them there can't be
different laws for different types of
people and that's what you're seeing in
this country if you're not going to have
a guy standing out there with something
right here to prevent people from just
fleecing you this is not like you know a
couple dollars this is Seven Grand from
two kids if this happens all over all of
their brick and mortars you're gonna
need a bigger insurance policy because
right now the numbers don't add up you
can't just write this off now they know
you can go in and you can steal and
they're not going to do anything about
that and now there really know because
it's on the five yep and now everybody
knows it's not policing by the way it's
I think it's 100 cotton isn't it your
stuff is so breathable Greg I've bought
thousands of dollars of Lululemon pants
yes I wore them on this show for three
years I know they're comfortable
the men's the men's section is actually
quite nice the golf pants the golf pants
they taper they're good there's moisture
wicking qualities you don't need to know
about that no no we have rain Dana I
want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now